well I'm joined Now by Hans Neiman and
by his lawyer Terence over if the first
question uh hands for you why have you
got your lawyer with you
well uh considering the the recent uh
case and settlement are some legal
questions
um you know my my lawyer might be able
to better answer and uh to be honest uh
I'm you know Terry and his team has been
frankly you know great and and helping
me resolve this case and uh I'm very
very thankful to them for believing in
me and you know this is not just a he's
not just my lawyer he's a friend he's a
confidante and he's someone who I trust
uh fully and uh that's why he's here
today okay so look you you are a chess
Prodigy no question you're a grand
master which you've got about title into
17 you're right the fourth best Junior
chess player in the world so you're a
brilliant chess player the question mark
that got put over your head came after
you beat Norway's world champion Magnus
Carlson this is back in Missouri in
September 2022 so a year ago and you
beat him ending a 53 game unbeaten
streak and as a result you're accused of
being a cheat and you're accused of
cheating in a particularly fascinating
manner which is the allegation was that
your coach had basically instructed you
to insert anal beads inside yourself
which he would then send remote signals
to uh first of all when that story broke
those allegations what was your reaction
well obviously it's very disheartening
to be accused of cheating after after
that Victory
um but you know uh
these things you know it happened and I
learned a lot from that time and uh it
really has taught me a lot of very very
important lessons about life and chess
and I think it's only strengthened my
resolve and it's only motivated me you
know further and uh it's it's shown me
that um you know with with the help of
people like Terry you know in life you
know it's really important to have
people who help you and that's why
because of this I've started a
scholarship where I'm giving away ten
thousand dollars to Talent chess players
throughout the world so you know I think
that uh you know when difficult things
happen to you in life you have to learn
from them and you have to uh you know
move forward and you know you can't live
in the past okay but just to be clear
you didn't cheat
of course not so what have you what have
you had to learn if you didn't cheat
well I think uh The Learning Experience
was more so the media attacking me and
uh all the you know trustworld you know
crashing down on me I think uh learned
you know dealing with that you know was
a learning experience you know dealing
with all that pressure and competing
under all that pressure but but again to
be clear on the specific allegation have
you ever used anal beads while playing
chess
not a question I ever thought I'd ask a
guest to be honest but
uh well you know your curiosity is a bit
concerning you know maybe you're
personally interested but uh I can tell
you no
okay categoric no
of course yes categorically no I
obviously I didn't I didn't make the
allegations I'm just repeating what was
put to you at the time as a result of
the furore that developed
um you were investigated by chess.com
they banned you while they did this and
they published a report uh saying that
you would likely cheated more than a
hundred times in online games you've
been admitted you had cheated I think
twice you said uh in online games on
chess.com when you were 12 and 16 but
denied ever doing so in an in-person
game is that an accurate assessment of
what went down
that's correct
so I guess the obvious question from
that is given you've admitted to
cheating
is it completely outrageous that people
thought you may have continued cheating
well let me just clarify that the
chess.com report where they you know
accuse me of cheating over 100 games is
completely defamatory and you know as
outlined in my lawsuit uh you know the
person who actually wrote that report
Danny wrench told me himself uh that
they knew that I had never cheated while
streaming and the most serious
accusations in that report
happened while I was streaming live on
Twitch and the only reason that they
banned me uh you know was because they
were finalizing you know merger with a
play Magnus group and their new you know
you know star Ambassador was making a
mockery of himself and they need to back
up his accusations didn't discredit me
so
trust.com's report accusing me of 100
games of cheating is frankly ridiculous
and the timing that they decided to ban
me you know only during this merger and
only after uh this accusation you know
it's absolutely ridiculous and and that
report should not be taken seriously
whatsoever but he also appears it's
important to note that it was a 51-page
hit piece right and at the end of those
51 Pages there was no evidence
whatsoever that he cheated online that
was the accusation that was what they
abandoned from that was what Magnus had
stated there was not a scintilla of
evidence to support any of that and
there still isn't I understand but just
to be clear again
um and when you did cheat the ones
you've admitted to what were the
circumstances of cheating
well I was 12 years old uh in the uh I
was very young it was not a
it was uh you know a tournament but it
was a childish mistake and something
I've admit to and I don't think that uh
something you do when you're 12 and
something you know with you know a
couple hundred bucks in the line uh
should have any yeah
well you use a a you know a chess engine
to to give you the moves
well you just well a computer or
something
uh someone was it was like an iPad
so someone was giving you moves from an
iPad
yes it was a a it was a very childish
thing I had no I didn't even understand
the seriousness of what was happening
but then you were 16 and did it again
was it the same the same thing again
when you were 16. when I when I was 16
this was not a prize money event these
were random meaningless games it's like
you know
it was a similar similar manner you see
so the first one you could put down to
being a 12 year old kid all right you
make a mistake you learn your lesson you
move on but to do it again four years
later when you're 16
it's only like four years ago why did
you do it again
well uh you know uh it was a
I I saw those use those games as
meaningless
um and they were meaningless there was
no money or anything attached to them
and um again it was a childish mistake I
was living on my own when I was 16.
um I was financially independent and uh
I felt a lot of pressure you know I just
simply wanted to to get a higher rating
on on the website but I want to make a
differentiation Pierce when you when you
talk about online chess and in person
chess this is a very very different
thing and you need to understand the
difference between that these online
games these are absolutely absolutely
meaningless and you know some of the
people who are accusing me you know uh
in these casual online games you know
you know some people are streaming you
know it's not you know you need to
really understand here's the problem I
don't like people that cheat in any form
of competitional sport because to me it
just kills the integrity and purity of
it and I guess you would agree with that
right
no of course so but you should
understand you know the difference
between when you're you know young child
and you're under severe pressure and and
you make a mistake and you know you
should also understand that uh when it
comes to over-the-board official
tournaments I've never cheated and
there's absolutely no evidence that I've
ever cheated
here's the problem with that I I like I
say when you're 12 all right I get it
but to do the same thing again when
you're 16 shows there's a pattern well
we only we only actually have your word
for it right I mean there might not be
hard evidence to have nailed you but you
can understand why people be suspicious
given your emissions I mean if I play
with my video if I play with my Village
friends at golf there's a kind of
Integrity to the to the way we play even
though there's no money on the line if
one of them cheated at golf and I caught
them and I might give them a pass
although it would just be Unthinkable
they would do that but if they did it
again I'd never play with them again
we understand Hans was 16 years old he
made a mistake we understand that you
have a different uh interpretation he
was playing online in a game that really
didn't matter at a young age we
understand and you're not wrong but to
try to extrapolate from the fact of
something that he did on an online game
when he was 16 and say once a cheater
always a cheater if you did something
when you were 16 I'm going to hold it
against you for the rest of your life we
think that's a little harsh and it
certainly doesn't properly characterize
all right but so why couldn't he answer
that question
sorry
yeah hands I mean it was really aim to
you you understand my analogy right if
people you know if you cheat in a sport
once
let me well I can give you analogy as
well so let's say that you know you know
you know
16 year old kid went into like a pickup
basketball game that is the equivalent
of the games that I cheated in at 16
years old is the equivalent of a
meaningless pickup basketball game so
let's say in a pickup basketball game
you know you know you know you did
something I don't know how that would
you know whatever you know you file the
inequal file or something like that
let's say you you know did that and pick
a boss volume do you think that that
should should Define my entire career
especially you know you're using you're
using you know computerized systems to
some way of to understand women in chess
I can't think of a more egregious way of
cheating than doing that you're using a
non-human brain to beat a human I mean
it's just it's free he did not do that
here but he didn't he did not do that
here meaning what he did back then what
he did about five years ago and then
about ten years ago you're correct he's
I he's admitted that and he's apologized
for that yeah but that has absolutely
nothing to do with what happened here
any nothing else could be closer to the
truth he played with Integrity he played
with honest see and he won that way so
yesterday I believe you played Vladimir
kramnik on chess.com and you beat him
and kramnick said afterwards I've
decided to stop playing on chess.com
from tomorrow on just too many obvious
cheaters on here nothing is done to
clean the platform from these small
Crooks harsh words but true what did you
make of that
well the criminal situation is quite
complex because I actually beat him
about a week ago and he made a video
that was a bit confusing but actually a
couple days ago I had private
correspondence with him where he told me
that he has personally has no issue with
me and where he said that uh he was not
meant to be an accusation whatsoever
blatant suggestion that you cheated
well that contradicts uh you know the
direct you know the the private
correspondence and email that he sent to
me why would he actually and why would
he infer you're a cheater in public in
the way that he did that was yesterday
oh he but he is he my name was never
mentioned you know he's just accused a
lot of people of cheating excuse
yeah but he's he he played that same day
he played against you know 10 other
people right and considering that I was
invited by him to Amsterdam to meet him
and to play games with him
um it seems a bit weird uh that you know
that he would do that you know and then
the next day supposedly accused me of
cheating so you know I understand that
how it might look but uh you know he's
privately reached out to me and I was
invited to Amsterdam I unfortunately
can't go um due to another conflict but
I hope to meet him and to discuss things
in more detail with him okay you sued um
the real damage of this also appears
isn't that the real damage as well so
whenever now someone beats someone
rather than acknowledge it and say that
I'll get better now this is set a
precedent that whenever someone beats
you well yeah
you take it away from them yes but I'm
unfortunately actions have consequences
if you admit you've cheated twice over a
four year period uh and you become a
grand master the year after the second
time and you announce only 20 now people
are gonna obviously guard dispersions
focus on those two isolated incidents
why don't you focus on them
the two your clients admitted of course
but the other the other hundreds of
matches that he's won are those totally
meaningless so you can always focus on
the shade I don't know I don't know I
can only majority I'm not judging your
client I'm just saying he's admitted to
cheating twice Over a four-year period
and that's why maybe people are in
meaningless games you know I mean people
do wonder they do wonder how did you
beat Magnus Carlson
um okay if you want to take that logic
you know you want to take that logic
right so I have proven my strength right
just outcomes themselves have said that
since I you know since they gave me a
short band before they said that since
then I have never cheated so
on their website I've beaten some of the
best players in the world I've performed
at the highest level on their website
which they they themselves say that I
didn't cheat in in addition to that
and over the board tournaments I have
continued to play Chess at a very very
high level I have
you know you know my ranking my ranking
did not just drop I continue to play
well even after this Victory I've proven
my my chest level and my chest strength
time and time again this is simply a
case of of you know where bullies or or
you know going after someone because
they threaten their business interests
of course he's a bully he used his
entire Empire he used his connections to
chess.com he leveraged his you know the
fact that there's a you know a merger
happening and he got all these people to
attack me and it was it's a bully it's a
simple thing but you know I don't you
know let people believe me I'm going to
stand up to him when I stood up to him
and you know I look forward to competing
him and against the board again and uh
you know I'm gonna you know do what I do
best and improve myself are you still
suing him are you still suing him for
100 million dollars
no you dropped that
the case has been resolved Pierce
yeah did he correct did he pay any money
or
we can't discuss that
okay out of Interest how do you how do
you disprove that you've used anal beads
to cheat
how can I you know prove it just prove a
negative it's like oh no no you expect
me but but let's first all discuss that
you know that is not a serious Theory
okay that was something that was taken
out of context and that that was never a
serious thing that was something that
the media caught up but that was you
know if you if you look at the the
consensus among chess players the
consensus among experts it is an
unequivocal fact that I have never
cheated in an over the board game so I
find you know but again I'm just
wondering how do you disprove it I mean
were you strip searched did they explore
cavities where do we go here
well through tournaments there are
security checks where they you know will
do you know very Security checks you
know metal detectors different scanners
um
would that pick up anal based
I don't know Pierce I I have no
genuinely
you should you should invite them on
your show and ask them that it appears
that that's the main topic of your
curiosity appears to be that as opposed
to the fact that you have a 19 year old
champion who defeated a champion who
defeated the whole world of Chess and
the largest cyber bullying case in
history the world of Chess versus Hans
Neiman and he's here to talk about it
and he's still a Victor and instead of
becoming bitter he became better and you
want to ask him about the anal beats
something he never said or never did we
don't know the answer to that question
Pierce maybe you can ask the anal B
people have them on your show and they
can explain it to you better I think it
will because it's actually a fast listen
I love chess I was my school my Prep
School you seem to love anal beads
better at Pierce well I was my Prep
School chess champion I never cheated
right so we have that uh we're different
right until somebody says that you did
until somebody says
the same age that your client cheated I
didn't cheat never crossed my mind would
never have cheated it at chess you're a
better person you're a better person
your words not mine Terence
uh but I'm just I'm genuinely curious it
was a massive story as you know it's why
you're famous outside of uh the Chess
World is because there was this
allegation made and it was fueled by the
world champion who couldn't understand
how in normal circumstances you would
beat him and then came Mrs lost the many
people of my same ranking many times so
this idea that it's a statistical
anomaly he can lose one game and and
that's the issue right he lost to people
similar age similar rating multiple
times recently so me beating him in a
singular game is not a statistical
anomaly right you know chess a lot of
the top players are very very good and
they're slim slim margins so anything
could happen in one game and you know
considering my recent rise I I you know
it's uh you know it's not gonna be the
last time that I beat him he hasn't
agreed to play you as I understand it is
he is he is he chickening out what's the
deal there no he has agreed to play me
he put out a public statement that he he
will play there's no date right
well when we were matched in tournament
which which is inevitable uh uh uh we
will play and will you allow yourself to
be strip searched just to roll out any
rumors
I find that question to be just you know
I can't take you seriously when you ask
those questions peers I'm sorry because
you're entertaining uh uh uh honestly an
allegation that should should not even
be taken seriously because it's it's
purely you know for you know for you to
get media attention when this when this
is it's not even a serious thing how
could how can you as a reporter take
that allegation seriously at all well I
understand Elon Musk uh no but I know do
you genuinely believe that no but dude
do you actually believe that that is the
case I don't know could you could you
even I don't know I know you're capable
of cheating because you've admitted it I
don't know how far you go
you cheated twice I've never cheated in
an over-the-board game I've never well
I'm clearly not I'm not capable and I've
never cheated over the board games
right we have your words right word it's
unequivocal chess.com themselves said
that right it is an unequivocal
statistical fact that I have never
cheated in over the board game and that
is something you cannot debate Elon Musk
as you know tweeted uh on what was known
as Twitter then is now X Talent hit to
Target no one else can hear genius hits
a Target no one can see because it's in
your butt
what did you feel when you read that
well I was a bit surprised
um you know uh I was surprised uh you
know I I didn't really think much of it
you know I I focused on competing and um
I don't let these things affect me and
uh my goal is to become the best chess
player in the world and and to give back
to chess players all around the world
and uh I think that chess is a beautiful
game that should be spread and that's
why I intend to do a lot more charity
work and give back to the communities
who helped me do you think when you play
Magnus Carlsen again you'll kick his
butt for one of a better phrase
you know I'll just let my chest speak
for itself
Heinz Neiman uh and Terence your lawyer
thank you both very much indeed
thank you